[Musique]
et
quand la femme vient donner un morceau ici, c'est
très difficile pour nous parce que nous n'avons pas de
lumière, nous utilisons la lumière tactile donc
ce jour-là, je suis très stressant à cause de
cette lumière tactile en utilisant la lumière tactile I'
J'insiste, même en faisant l'
injection sans lumière, vous verrez que c'est
difficile pour
nous
maintenant que nous avons la lumière maintenant, ce que
je prévois, c'est que je veux économiser de l'
argent pour avoir un réfrigérateur que
je stockerai  mes vaccins et autres
médicaments qui ont besoin de régler
la température de [Musique
]
[Musique]
donc il y a 600 millions d'Africains
sans accès à l'électricité et le
Nigeria est le plus grand euh a les
taux les plus élevés de cette euh une
population électrifiée à travers l'Afrique euh  Le
Nigeria est également le plus grand
marché potentiel pour les grds miniers et donc les mines
sont une solution clé pour électrifier au
moins 30 % de la population non
électrifiée. Le
Nigeria a donc le
potentiel, mais il est entravé par une
série de contraintes, notamment des
contraintes financières et politiques.  au
moment [Musique] [Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Eng
f
J'utilise ce solaire à
cause du prix élevé du
gaz si j'utilise du gaz, il ne pourra pas
m'emmener avec ma propre famille,
c'est pourquoi je le rejoignais  cela m'amène à
me faire bénéficier de
[Musique]
ça